thank you peter for the for your kind
uh introduction uh i'm uh kazugomi
and we are uh one of the new
uh industry partners for the uh simon's
institute
i'm glad to be a part of it and uh so
let me just
give you a quick introduction of entity
research
we started out our operations about a
year ago and then
became the part of uh um industry
partner for simon's research
uh since then these are the areas that
we are doing that the research at the
entity
r d center in uh silicon valley uh
quantum computing uh
crypto and information security and the
medical information
i'd like to focus on those first two uh
quantum
and the crypto side of the house uh for
this presentation quickly
so for the quantum computing uh side
that the type of research we uh that
team
is conducting is uh focusing on
that uh basically quantum annealing uh
type of machines
uh using that uh fiber optics
and uh basically laser oscillator
optical parameter oscillators
and then we uh basically run the short
pulse
of laser lasers and then they uh we just
control that
that pulse of laser uh bit uh
using those delay lines uh here and then
we have implemented that initially it's
just a delay lines
and then uh now we're using that the
more sophisticated the
uh logics to control the delay
uh using those fpgas and uh based on
machines
and then we insert the pulse uh
depending upon the calculated that delay
now with this machine uh we have
uh done a couple of uh simulations and
then this is uh
initial uh results that we
seen uh that um so
that the graph here uh that the
uh the comparison of with the d-web
machines
and then the cim which is here in the
ising machine
that's basically the machine that i have
just shown you that
uh that composite of it uh so
as you see that uh
that the cim is showing a pretty
good performance so far
so uh we continue working on it to
um add more
well understanding this mechanism a
little better
and also uh certainly adding more uh the
spins
uh to be able to solve more realistic
problems uh switching a gear i just
give you a quick recent work that the
team
has done i'm going to introduce
three uh the recent works uh the first
one
is that the chosen cyber cipher text
security from
injective trapdoor functions uh this was
that uh presented at the crypto
2020 in august and then the chosen as
that the best paper
uh from there basically uh this is
to uh resolve that the problem
uh that was outstanding for more than 30
years that
uh how to really create that the secure
environment secure calculations based
upon the core function
of pke public key encryptions
this core function is injected trapdoor
functions and then and then the create
that
uh security level of uh in the cca2
uh which is the strongest security
challenges so
um and then that the
basically that the team has worked on
this
uh and then prove that you can uh
construct that uh that this type of
securities
uh so so that's the work that the team
has done and the second thing
is that uh the title in this in
distinguishability observation
from well-funded assumptions so this is
uh the the team is has tackled on the
observation
uh pro program uh and
uh uh in uh basically to
address the indistinguishably in
indian i o uh in this indistinguishable
uh observation and
there were some uh many people were
i understand that have been working on
it and then the can you make that
i o uh using a program site
and uh and
this paper uh have uh
proven that based upon uh
the well well it has proven that uh
io can be uh constructed
uh from the well-founded uh assumptions
so so that's the uh uh that's the new
uh one another recent uh achievements uh
coming up
from uh from this team
and uh last not the least uh uh
that from the uh this uh
uh cryptography and
information security team they're
working on also
on the blockchain uh analytics and then
to understand the blockchain mechanism
and so on and so forth so this
particular
work that the team has done with regard
to the blockchain
is uh is the following so uh basically
the problem set
that uh the team is looking at is that
uh
well something like a bitcoin that the
blockchain with the
proof of proof of work and uh when you
look at the
blockchain uh well bit uh bitcoin uh
the situation right now that there are
uh
uh many instead of uh
individual uh doing the minings
uh that they each individual typically
joined the mining pools
and then those mining pools are becoming
larger
and larger so one may
think that those mining tool will be
super big and then we'll
gain more than 51 more than half
of the shares of this blockchain
mining activities and which creates that
the centralization risks
basically if you have if one party
have the power more than 50 then then
that may
uh basically can break the uh block
so so that's that's the kind of um
the problem uh set that the team has
working on
now uh for this particular work two
minutes
thank you uh for this particular work
that uh
is uh has approached this program
uh problem uh by applying the game
theory uh to this problem and then
what as a result it was found that
uh to share uh well to maximize that
uh return uh for each mining pool's
perspective
they should just maintain that
10 to 15 percent of the shares and then
if you go
above and beyond that that should
really adversary impacting their uh
profitability or the return therefore
based upon the game siri that uh
that the share will be standing the
share of the each mining
pools uh are standing somewhere around
10 to 15
which is actually when you look at the
real status of the bitcoin
that's what uh uh what it is so
it's kind of being uh proven from a
theoretical perspective
so these are the just examples of
a recent outcome
from entities and if you are interested
in learning more
or discussing more of those things just
let me know we'll
happy to well i can happy to
connect you to each researcher so thank
you very much
for your time